Thank you
[Applause] thank you thank you
For this great gift
to the city of Forli in Romagna after
the tragedy we have experienced it is a
moment of great closeness on the part
of the European commission of our
government I had no doubts there were those who
thought you would be forgotten but instead
we have
this continuous feeling of closeness
of attention of that thing that gives us
hope for the solution of the many
problems we have
had thank you thank you very much for
Being here Thank you very much for Being
here
for and
R
After Us affected Us We immediately
clear  Europe Commission and had No Doubt
that Europe Commission and italian
government would be Us Close to us some
people would forg Us we have
with
and
Here the mayors of the entire
territory of the province of Forlì are present it is a
path that we share and therefore on
my part  from the whole
territory a big thank you for this
beautiful moment of sharing and closeness
Thank you
Welcome President
VL Welcome President Meloni now I
'll say An applause also to Giorgio
[Applause]
Meloni
Thank you for keeping your word
When he came and together I fly over the areas
of this land so devastated last
May the work of the minister
together with the
Meloni government in action will allow us to have
this additional billion and 200 million
euros with the pnrr funds for
investments in the
territory Prime Minister meloni and
your determination We will be able to re
the
addal
together with the general commissioner
son and these
extraordinary mayors and mayors
local administrators and administrators
we will try to do our best to
restart this beautiful land to a large extent they have already
done so
[Applause]
thank you
truly a pleasure an honor to have you here
together with our president of
Council of
Ministers honor and burden to be
government commissioner for the
reconstruction of the territories that
were devastated by the flood of
May
last year Thank You
Very
min
but Seeing this institutional synergy
not only at an Italian level At a
local level with President Bonaccini the
President Lauca, all
the mayors of the Province of Forli
Cesena are present here and seeing your closeness, you
represent the European Union.
As was done in the dark years of
Covid-19, I am sure that together we will be
able to give this region to the
regions  flooded to the
flooded lands an even better face than
the one they had before because
the representatives of the Region deserve it
But above all the
citizens of this region deserve it as well as
Marella Toscana which was also
flooded Thank you for being here with
us
Those Dark
Years we  are Sure that together We will
be able to give this Reg even a
situation than It was before and that
the representes
of
[Applause]
So again good afternoon everyone
Thank you for being here thanks to
President Bonaccini thanks to Mayor
Zattini thanks to the commissioner son
of  president of the province to the other
mayors who spoke but
above all I want to
thank not only the minister but also
members of the government the president
of the European commission Ursula von
Derlien who returns to these lands
after the last visit a few days and a
few weeks after the flood 8 months ago
with very important results that
we have built together in recent
months
Comm pres of prov prov as
all all minit Anders of italian
government first and
iad President
Comm Coming Back After
here
when we were Here the last time
President von derl brought
European solidarity  but he also brought his commitment
not to leave these lands alone to do
what the European Commission and the
European Union could have done
to lend a hand and the fact that he is here
today again when we can
present the results of the
commitment is me a  symbol of great seriousness
of great concreteness for which I
truly believe that all the citizens of this
region, not only of this region,
must thank President von
Derl.
We have spent these months together a lot, we
have worked in a very
profitable way. For this reason, I also want to thank
all the  offices, staff, I want
to thank Born Cyber ​​In short, all the
people who help us do this
work and the first and most
important thing that needs to be mentioned is the
review of the National Recovery
and Resilience Plan. You know that we have
started a review of the
National Plan  of recovery and resilience,
something that was said not to be possible but
which instead was not only possible but
necessary taking into account the sad reality of
the changed context in which we
find ourselves operating and in that revision
of the PNRRR which frees up resources for 21
billion euros  'it is a very
important commitment in favor of the
flooded areas. So obviously starting from
Emilia Romagna for a further
billion 200 million euros which are
obviously added to the resources already
allocated by the
government
very relevant and
useful so like to than all of the people
involved the sta all of the people in
particular be for doing this and Being
involved in this and For The help that
we have received the most important
Thing We have been doing revision Of The
National recovery resilience Plan Which
we started As you all know
necessary was Because  of the ched
framework we are in
andion Of The National recovery It was
possible
to 21 billion and
out
Billi
are
these resources, in addition to guaranteeing the
safety of the built-up areas of
the river basins exposed to
hydrogeological risk, will also allow us to carry
out environmental recovery actions
mitigation of the effects of
climate change by guaranteeing a
decidedly higher level of
flood risk management control but also the restoration and
redevelopment of the public institutional ID assets
of the
socio-health structures of the schools of the
sports infrastructures of the
energy networks, that is, with these resources we
carry out reconstruction but  we also do
something that is equally important, even
more important if we want it, which is
the prevention of any
further events of this
nature
risks necessary to Tackle the climate
Change and the Effect of the climate
Change and this Will lead to a High
level in  terms of control for the risks
of floods and increases resilience and
Will also Help regenerate Urban areas
regenerate
reconstruct
SCH
Reg this priority among the objectives
of the pnrr has another consequence which in my opinion
is very important which is the
timetable. You know that the
timing of the  The PN of the resources that are
spent with the PNRR is a
very quick timeline and inserting these
objectives into the PNRR requires us to work
quickly because our
timetable will be a ready program
that provides for the identification of all Eh
G punctual interventions within the third
quarter of 2024 the awarding of
all contracts by the second
quarter of 2025 the completion of
90% of the works by the end of 2026
That means having to work and work
quickly Sorry
eh A little
fast
includ
requires Us to be Act very fast  because
including These tets In The National
recy requires Us to be Fast and very
punct be Time Because We need to identify them
clearly this work
adds up this important objective
adds up to the work that the government has already
carried out Ursula will not want it if we
also say  on this we make a
quick summary of the work that the
government has carried out so far with
decree 61. We have allocated almost 1
billion 800 million for the
maintenance of the production system and
employment levels with subsequent decree 88
another 2 and a half billion for the
public reconstruction over 120 million
for the first contributions to
private reconstruction 100 million for
businesses I try to go a little slower
then another 149 million were added
with a subsequent provision with the
work of the son commissioner who I
also have to thank for the 2.5  billion
allocated for public reconstruction,
a sum equal to 1 billion has already been made available to local authorities.
600 million to these resources are
added others equal to approximately 1
billion, already available to the
commissioner, 100 million have already been disbursed
to families for the
immediate support autosistem contribution
60,000 days of redundancy fund
200 million for self-employed workers
another 600 They are already available to
the commissioner the resources
we are talking about today are
additional resources compared to all this
work and
top but It's extremely important that
through Low decree 61  We allocated 1 800
Million for the for supporting the
production Systems and the employment
levels and with the Another government
measure number 88 We manage to allocate
additional 200 Millions for the
reconstructions 100 Millions have been
Made
available the family Another measure
Which was
already
available Bil Millions  Which already
been allocated forru
and 1. billion
Milli locor and
on
Days Lay
pay to the
workers
Add it should be added that the support
of the European Union is not
limited to the funds provided in the pnrr it
also extends to the funds allocated under the
European Fund  solidarity was the first
theme we talked about in our
previous visit to Emilia Romagna. There
is an instance there that is handled by the
Department of Civil Protection for
which Minister Musumeci must be thanked
with the contribution obviously
of the Emilia-Romagna region which
could bring  an
additional contribution of 378 million euros if I'm not mistaken
but 95 were already
almost immediately very
quickly advanced by the
European Commission, therefore another
important commitment which I also want
to state because we are here to
bring concrete answers
Europe disc after the first  We And Fund
forment of CIV Prot with the
contribution And We need to Thank min
mus for this And there is addition if
I'm not mistaken contribution of 378
Millions Which have been Made available
I don't want to dwell further
clearly with President von derl
in the bilateral meeting we
had just now we also discussed
many other matters which are all
specific matters which see us
collaborating starting from the next
very important European Council European Council
in which we will once again
discuss the review of the
multi-annual budget of the review of  midterm and
there are, in short, important issues ranging
from the need to guarantee
support for Ukraine to resources
for migration,
migration and let's say the
Italian approach of working on the
external dimension rather than thinking of
solving the problem when it arrives in
Europe is one of the  issues on
which the president of the
European Commission and I have worked a lot
together in recent months I
also want to thank her for this and I
want to thank her and I really close to
participate on January 28th
in the Italy Africa conference which, as you know, we
are celebrating in Rome and  will see the
participation of several African heads of state
and government to talk and
continue to talk about the
European approach of the Italian approach with the
Mattei plan, comparing ourselves with these
countries with a new approach, let's not
say
predatory, certainly an equal-to-
equal approach that with these  Nations She knows she
can build important things in the long
term Ursula vonder derl She understood this
much earlier than others and I want to
thank her for her presence and for the
contribution she will bring
[Laughter]
Thanks
ok We can do this Sal wants me to
skip it or I'll go
by min min
thick thank you thank you
Giorgia dear Giorgia dear
minister Thick governor Bonaccini
Where is Mayor Zattini sitting there Thank you dear
all of you it is truly extremely
touching For me to come back here again to
Emilia Romagna where I came to
visit last May after immediately
after  the devastating floods that have
hit you and I will never forget
these devastations that have
caused terrible these terrible
floods and what I remember most of
all is this mud mud mud everywhere
and ruins of the houses that have been destroyed
all the devastation caused
by the  flood
[Music]
Andy Each
other Each other even cook for each
other
but what I remember equally so
vividly is also the enormous solidarity
that immediately spread among
people the will the desire the help
that each provided the help to each
other Men  Women children all together
helping each other who helped each other supported each other
And they even cooked a G for
each other I was even given
a piadina which I still remember today I
still remember the smell I remember it was
still C it sounds like a
request let's say the mayor
has
already sent me something I'll take the next
piadina
home
and the European Union and this is the
message has been at your side since
the very first day And we will continue to
do so we are today And we will continue to
be has
excellent
the cooperation has been  truly
excellent it was exceptional this has
already been mentioned it has already been said the
review was successful it was a
review which was that of the next
generation Eu your famous pnrr and we
have already foreseen we have dedicated 1
billion 200 million specifically to
this region
as
back
ex Protection Rep Public
infrastructure is needed specific in
Region but
more we want to help you get back on your
feet to be more resilient to
improve
flood prevention for the restoration of
public infrastructure structures but
obviously we are doing it and we will do
even
more in addition to the pnrr  there are obviously
other funds for crops the
farmers of Emilia Romagna have
suffered heavily from the consequences of the
floods so we have made
60 million euros available to them which
were disbursed on the basis of the reserves
of the reserves for the Agriculture emergency
and also very important the reform of the
cohesion fund a new Milestone has been inserted a
new milestone
in the revised plan which therefore allows us
to
redirect important funds for
reconstruction and
disaster response can help contribute to
revitalizing the communities and the city that
cities that have been affected by
natural catastrophes exactly
as occurred in
2017 as a consequence of the earthquake
that hit central Italy and Eu
[Music]
sol
and we have
also mobilized the Solidarity Fund
you have already received an advance of around
95  million Eur for emergency situations
to clean up for
recovery and
recovery activities other funds will arrive in the
coming
months
together
Will but we have seen throughout Europe
and The Whole World that our Planet is
heating up with Extreme weather events
that Will become More  frequent and
therefore what is good for the climate
is also Good for our Economy If we
prevent and Fight climate
Change mentioned Eh a whole series of
prevention measures for which I will not
go back I will not dwell on these
what I want to say that what we
have witnessed  what we
also see throughout Europe is that there is a
warming of the globe, a warming
of the world and of the planet and
extreme climate events will become
even more frequent so we must
face we must fight and
prevent climate change because
what is worth is worth while  also
good for our
economies
energy techn it TR
ination
PNR
Commission
Pay
and thanks to the fact voo You have already
included in your pnrr state And this
is very important because you are
also investing in the in the
deployment of renewable energies of
clean energies of clean technologies
l  'Italy is absolutely in line with the
roadmap as regards
the implementation of the PNRR. The
commission has already disbursed the fourth
installment at the end of December which
means that half of the PNRR funds have
already been disbursed and this is
great news.  When I came here in
May I you Stay strong and Europe is with
you
I BT
Heart
St as
takes blow Europe remains
cones
when when I came
here when I came here in May
I told you that you had to stay strong and
that Europe  is and would have been at
your side and now I want to tell you from the bottom
of my heart that we will continue to stand
by your side for as long as
necessary for your recovery Team
Bota Europe remains with you
thank you
[Applause]
arrabi
mayor